hey natalie hi nice to see you nice to
see you too i can't tell you how excited
i was to see that jane foster was back
in this i didn't even realize how much i
missed her until i saw this movie what
was it like for you coming back to the
mcu as mighty thor
well thank you for saying that and it
was incredible to get to come back as
the mighty thor and was just such an
opportunity to have jane get to
not just reprise her role as this you
know doggedly curious astrophysicist but
also as a superhero was pretty exciting
i was obsessed with your arms in this
movie too i mean for a lot of reasons i
was so excited for mighty thor but i
know you transformed your body uh what
was it like for you kind of living in
that new body emotionally and physically
uh it was it was so fun to get to be
tasked with being a bigger character i
don't think it's often
if ever in your career that you know as
a 5'3 actress someone asks you to play a
six-foot character so to just get to
imagine um you know even the mindset of
someone who walks into a room and is
intimidating physically as is is an
incredible thing as as a you know small
woman to get to to play
i love it um i know you've talked about
having your kids on set did you have a
moment a favorite moment of yours when
they got to see you as the superhero on
set
it was definitely fun to have them get
to see me like in a cape and flying and
you know it was just wild the first time
i put on the whole superhero costume i
remember calling tyken being like have i
told you how grateful i am for this
opportunity this is the coolest thing
i've ever gotten to do i mean it's it's
really extraordinary
did you ever think you'd come back to
the mcu either in another character or
within the thor film i think i thought
anything was possible you know um
but of course it wasn't until tyka came
with the comic books of
jane becoming the mighty thor that i
thought it might be possible
yeah that's so cool you know i want more
i selfishly want more i also kind of
want a mighty thor and valkyrie spin-off
film you and tessa thompson have such
great chemistry
really you do that would be a dream
have you told psyche this do we need to
get him on board
sure sure
can be the agent of
of all of us
okay i'll i will try my best to make
this happen um so i didn't realize
people were going to talk this much
about it but were you surprised about
the naked thor scene that people clearly
can't stop talking about
um i think that that was
very clearly going to be a popular
moment i think
i think that was not a big surprise
i didn't think it would dominate the way
that like is all over social media i was
like okay people are people are ready
for that i mean
it's it's it's a it's a beautiful sight
i love that um
what is your favorite part you know
aside from like the physicality and
you're playing the superhero what's your
favorite part about kind of the the
story arc that we're getting to see with
jane foster this time around
i just love that she's able to do so
many different things i think you see
her be really powerful you also see her
quite vulnerable yeah you see her
focused on her science you see her also
you know
be able to have romance
so it allows her to show many different
sides of being human i think and and i
think that's
quite rare
yeah um did christian bale freak you out
on set the way you freaked us out
watching the film
oh yeah it was so scary i mean the first
day he came on set we were all kind of
looking at each other like this is
terrifying like this is intense
terrifying in reality yeah
um what do you like about
this villain because you know we've seen
so many villains in the mcu but i was
telling like people after i saw this
movie i was like this is one of my
favorite villains
well of course christian is such a
talented actor um that you know it is
so believable in every moment so scary
um so moving um
so thought-provoking uh but it really is
i think a villain that you can relate to
which is the most interesting kind
um you know it's it's certainly someone
who
is is
sympathetic in a very interesting way
yeah well congratulations on the movie i
know your fans are gonna want more of
mighty thor so
thank you fingers crossed
thanks so much
you